while staying with our coverage from Lib
Dem conference we're joined now by the
party's Foreign Affairs spokesman chicka
Runa thank you for being on the program
with us this morning
so are the Lib Dems on favor of revoking
article 50 and canceling practice
altogether well so long as this
Parliament persists Sophie of course
we're going to carry on campaigning for
a people's vote with remain on the
ballot which we will be of course
backing but that's an issue for this
Parliament if we enter a general
election which i think is probably quite
likely in November we will continue
providing that clear distinctive voice
as the biggest and strongest remain
party in this country by committing if
we have a Liberal Democrat majority
government to reverting revoking article
50 we believe that a victory in an
election like that would give us a clear
democratic mandate to do that and it
would thankfully bring an end to the
chaos that we have seen swiftly so we
can actually focus on the big issues
this country is facing how do we
properly fund our NHS how do we build a
fairer more equal society and transform
our dysfunctional economy you see you
say that you'd have a mandate for it but
at the same time I can't help but wonder
if it is really credible that a party
with Democrats in the actual title of
the party would be willing to overturn
the biggest Democratic vote we've
actually seen in British history without
even putting the question specifically
about the people well look we actually
want to see Parliament functioning so
that's why you have seen this party
arguing against the shutdown and
probation of Parliament that's what it
is to be democratic and we want to see
things determined at the ballot box
through votes and that's what you would
do in a general election I know it suits
people on the other side of the argument
particularly the extreme Bret suitors
who I think actually represent a
minority in our country to somehow say
that we had one vote in 2016 and somehow
democracy stopped at that point in any
further votes or mandates that we have
after that point don't count well that's
just not the way British democracy works
I could run with your argument if it was
a case of us saying no in no way shape
or form should we reference
it's back to the people but generally
the people in this country have their
say on the big issue through general
elections or referendums we're talking
about general election because of course
your party also voted against having an
early election when Boris Johnson put
that department when do you actually
want to see one happen once we have
secured the extension to article 50
which is now provided through the been
act of Parliament and once that comes
into effect and we can be absolutely
sure that there is no risk that in
holding a general election this country
falls off a cliff then fine let's go
ahead and have that general election and
see if we can resolve some of the mess
we've seen created by the big two
parties in British politics look I think
something fundamentally is going on
right here Sophie I was campaigning in
the cities of London and Westminster
with our team there I'm our candidate
there in the general election and I was
going to areas which it's unheard of to
think would vote anything other than
conservative where we see a collapse in
the conservative vote and that's because
we are seeing right now a
reconfiguration of British politics it's
interesting that you are going to be
fighting the seat over cities of London
and Westminster currently held of course
by the Conservatives and when I last
interviewed you on the show we did it in
Stratham where you were formerly an MP
and you said this is the community I'm
from and I grew up in this is my
community my family is here so why would
I leave it why would you leave it when
no one has an indefinite right to
represent a constituency in perpetuity
and I'm of course sad to be leaving
Stretton and to be clear this was my
decision we actually had a fantastic
candidate in Helen Thompson in Stratham
who'd already led a very strong European
election campaign earlier this year in
the constituency which saw the Liberal
Democrats win comfortably taking seven
of the eight wards and I didn't think it
was right to elbow her out of the
situation very strong candidate and also
be frank with you Sophie I wasn't
particularly relishing the prospect of
coming up against what I knew in the new
Labour Party not the old Labour Party
that selected me
ten years ago but the New Labour Party
that I'd be facing a pretty vile awful
an appalling campaign and I feel I owe a
duty of care to my staff and my family I
didn't really want to put them through
that but also we see of course the
cities of London and Westminster isn't
just a symbol nationally it is a global
symbol of open international liberal
values and it is currently represented
by a member of parliament who failed to
vote to block No Deal and who represents
a party which has basically become a
right-wing populist nationalist party I
mean what you saw with the ejection of
21 conservative MPs including Sam keema
who we are incredibly happy to now have
in the Liberal Democrats wasn't just an
injection of you know heavyweight
substantial individuals who command
respect across the House of Commons you
actually saw the objection of an entire
tradition the One Nation Disraeli
tradition from the Conservative Party
that was a message saying to them
there's no longer a home for you a party
like that cannot possibly adequately
represent an international global
community like that we find in the
cities of London and Westminster you
mentioned some jira there he of course
has not become the eighteenth Lib Dem MP
you've seen defections from the Labour
Party people such as yourselves and also
from the Conservative Party is there a
risk that the only thing that unites you
is your desires try and stop braixen no
look it's much more than that and I
think people you know misunderstanding
what's going on here
yes remain leave is indicative of
whether you want the UK to continue to
be a member of the European Union but
it's about much more than that it's
indicative of holding they sat a set of
liberal international open values where
you believe in multilateral cooperation
countries working together to improve
the lots of their people you believe in
the rule of your you believe in
upholding human rights that is the new
divide now I get you know between
frankly socially liberal
internationalists and on the other hand
authoritarian social conservatives which
you see increasingly the Tory party
representing in this country so I
actually think British politics now
is less class-based than it once was and
it's actually less left-right it's
actually more about whether you're
liberal authoritarian and the
authoritarian part of the you know
politics here is represented by the
Conservative Party and the clue is in
the name of the Liberal Democrats we are
the biggest and strongest remain party
but it's really about championing and
defending liberal values well let's talk
about liberal values shall we because
one of the defectors was Phillip Lee the
former Conservative MP in 2017 he
abstained on a vote on equal marriage
the year after he proposed that
immigrants come in to settle in Britain
she'll have to first prove they don't
have HIV is that someone you're
comfortable with being in same party
well you'll have to ask Phillip about
that all I know you know he's a former
GP very well respected across the House
of Commons his heart beats in a liberal
direction and I know that he's meeting
some of those who you know had concerns
about things that he said or done in the
past here at our conference but one of
the reasons that he has been arguing for
us to stay in the European unit is
because he thinks free movement and
immigration is a good thing so he can
speak for himself but I am confident
that he has our liberal values that and
as those that have been in this party
will tell you a lot longer than me if
fundamentally after a discussion and
we're having these kinds of discussions
with people it's clear that somebody
doesn't have our values they won't be in
this party but he clearly does and
that's why he is a Liberal Democrat
member of parliament so do you think
that abstaining on about on equal
marriages demonstrates the liberal
values well he supports equal marriage
and that's what matters right now I mean
look you can go and look into what
people have said and done in the past
I've been pretty critical of what my
party has done in the past in coalition
government of course Phillip was part of
that coalition government but I'm
confident looking at what has happened
particularly under Joseph Ince's
leadership that things change and this
party has changed which is unchanged for
the better reference to the same values
but that's why people are flocking to us
not just members of parliament we've got
over 120,000 members now there is an
energy and enthusiasm and optimism
positivity here which I have to say I
haven't experienced elsewhere
and just a quick final thought because
we are a little bit pressed for time now
and if there is an election we think
will be sooner rather than later with
the Lib Dems be prepared to go into
coalition again look we want to change
the voting system we think this
first-past-the-post voting system is
broken and we need a system and
proportional representation and with
proportional representation that will
need two more coalition governments so
we don't have any problem with the
concept of a coalition government which
you see across the continent in
different countries but lets us be clear
the two parties as they are currently
configured with their current leadership
are not parties but frankly we could see
ourselves doing business with right now